this video features basically all of the
law discovered in the network test
version of the game and it's split into
two parts part one talks about
everything to do with the erd tree and
the golden order and part two begins
here and it talks about everything to do
with the stars and glintstone sorcery
these used to be two videos and i meant
to release them like a month ago so i'm
sorry for that
next week we'll all be playing elden
ring but until then i still think this
video will serve as a good foundation
for the law that you're going to
discover as you play i can't wait to
discover it all with you but without
further ado let's begin
one of the very first pieces of law that
you're confronted with is the fact that
you're maidenless and fully divorced
from the strength of runes
naroons are your currency they're tiny
fragments of the shattered elden ring
and make use of them most enlightened
tarnished require the help of someone
called a finger maiden these maidens
serve a faction called the two fingers
incantations from this faction rely on
faith and are for the most part
benevolent healing spells things like
heal or urgent heal or cure poison they
all read the maidens serve the two
fingers by guiding the tarnish to grace
in accordance with its mighty will
now remember tarnished were once spurned
by the grace of gold and the greater
will they were rejected and
unsurprisingly rejection is also a spell
of the two fingers and i feel like as
tarnished we're going to have to decide
whether we really want to serve this
greater will even after it rejected us
for so long this greater will requires
nothing less than total obedience and
the rejection miracle reads hark
tarnished if you truly walk in faith you
must be prepared to reject all else
so with all of this you'd think then
that melano our maiden is a maiden of
the two fingers then right
but she's not there is something for
which i must apologize
i've acted the finger maiden
yet can offer no guidance
i am no maiden
my purpose
was long ago lost
so in a way we are still maidenless
melina is just playing the role of one
all she asks in return is that we take
her with us to the foot of the herd tree
she's searching for her purpose
given to me by my mother inside the
archery
long ago
for the reason that i yet live
burned
and bodiless
we can't yet say who her mother was or
why she was inside the herd tree but i
think we can guess how she's been burned
and i think it has to do with that
marking around her closed eye
this symbol is a marking with three
digits and it looks quite similar to the
flame of frenzy incantation which reads
an incantation from the maddening three
fingers causes the yellow flame of
frenzy to burst forth from the caster's
eyes this incantation can drive human
foes mad those whose eyes are afflicted
with the flame of frenzy are racked with
maddening pain and unstoppable tears so
it's possible that melano has been
burned by the flame of frenzy
furthermore this is an incantation of
the three fingers who are a much more
ominous faction than the two fingers
that we just mentioned earlier so on one
hand we have the two fingers a group
with healing incantations that enlist
tarnished for use by the greater will
and on the well the same hand we have
the three fingers whose incantations can
drive one mad with the flame of frenzy
the implication is obviously that these
finger factions were once part of a
greater whole but they split and now are
clearly reaching for different things
but let's move on from melaner you know
it's possible that i'm reaching by
saying that she's a part of the three
fingers but i do want to talk about them
some more
they spell the flame of frenzy it causes
the madness status effect to build up
and when you get the madness status
effect this happens
you see flame and you clutch at your
eyes you also take a massive amount of
damage and it's just so similar to the
frenzy mechanic from bloodborne right
which was a status effect that drove you
mad when you saw parts of the eldritch
truth similarly i think this madness
effect in elden ring probably means that
there's a terrible truth here that is
simply excruciating to see
and do you know who else saw flame
the prophets the prophet blindfold reads
blindfold of exiled prophets who foresaw
that their faith would end in flames and
were persecuted and driven from their
homes as a result
after all what uses eyesight to those
who claim to know the true path
the fabric of their robes scrapes
against their skin like a file and the
rickety cartwheel around the neck warns
passersby not to lend an ear to their
meandering sermons
those in power feared this prophecy so
much that they exiled they tortured and
they ridiculed the prophets who saw it
so if these prophets are related to the
three fingers and the flame of frenzy
you know they did see flame after all
well then it's no wonder then that those
three fingers were cut off from the
other two
obviously we don't know why seeing flame
is a terrible truth but i'm guessing it
has something to do with the guidance of
grace the greater will
and also the old trees
so that brings us to the earth trees the
earth tree is that enormous golden tree
in the distance and according to the
official website the olden ring is the
source of its power another way of
thinking about that is actually that the
old tree might be a sort of parasitic
plant feeding off the power of the olden
ring which is obviously pretty sinister
when you think about it that way similar
to the age of fire in dark souls there
was an entire age centered around this
tree called the age of the herd tree and
from this golden herd tree many gifts
and graces were bestowed upon those in
the lands between one such gift were
tears of life considered blessings from
the tree from a gameplay point of view
these tears are really heavily linked to
your healing flasks the crimson and
cerulean flasks tell us that they are
modeled after a golden holy chalice that
was once graced by a tear of life and
even the flask of wondrous physic is
supposedly a relic of the physic
chemists priests of the earth tree we
can see many minor herb trees growing in
the distance as well and while we can't
visit any in the network test i'm
guessing based on previous games that
they probably give you tears that let
you get more healing flask charges or
increase the strength of your healing
according to the japanese item
description the two healing flasks are
traditionally handed to the tarnished by
their finger maiden when you first meet
and as we know these are maidens of the
two fingers and since these flasks are
blessed by the earth tree these maidens
of the two fingers probably serve the
will of the herd tree as well so those
two things are linked now and to serve
the will of the earth tree is one thing
but it appears that there's another
faction that worship a force even
further up this divine chain
they're called fundamentalists you know
they think they worship the core the
basic rules and they worship the golden
order or the golden law that the elden
ring provided and we know that this
golden law is something that shattered
along with the olden ring we learn about
these fundamentalists through an
incantation called litany of proper
death a litany is a sort of holy recital
and this is a holy incantation that
devastates undead enemies it gives them
a proper death and its description reads
an incantation used by golden order
fundamentalists any failed by this
incantation cannot be revived you can
use this in the network test against
these skeleton enemies for example and
they never get up again also the
japanese description of a holy water pot
goes on to read the golden law does not
permit the logic to live in death
and the japanese word for logic is
interesting because it's the exact same
word that karth used in dark souls when
he was talking about the logic of the
world
you'll recall in that game gwyn broke
the logic of the world and created an
endless age of fire which came with a
side order of undeath and now in elden
ring the logic of the world has been
shattered in the exact same way and
guess what it seems like a sort of
undeath is occurring once again in this
game as well despite desperate attempts
by golden order fundamentalists to
restore the logic of the world and to
purge these newly arisen dead so let's
just take a moment to recap the order of
these divine concepts the olden ring is
a source of power so powerful that it
commanded the stars
it defined the logic of the world with
its golden order which is a type of law
and the elden ring is the source of the
odd tree's power which led to an age of
the earth tree during this age golden
grace filters down through the branches
of the tree to the lands between and it
blesses some and spurns others
like the tarnished who were rejected and
then at some stage the olden ring
shattered
along with it its golden lore shattered
and the age of the earth tree seems to
have ended because of this
now closer to the current events of the
game a force called the greater will is
so desperate to hold on to its previous
power that even the exiled tarnished
have been brought back into the fold you
know paradigms have shifted now and now
power is up for grabs
before the ring was shattered and
probably during the age of the earth
tree the lands between were ruled by
queen marika the eternal
she's clearly a sort of immortal and she
even had demi-god children
so far we can be almost certain of two
of her children there's godric the
demigod boss of stormvale castle and
godwin who was one of the first demigods
to fall to the rune of death
we don't know much else about america
except that you can choose to resurrect
at her statues sometimes which does
suggest to me that she has an affection
or maybe at least a use for the
tarnished especially now that the ring
has shattered so how exactly did the
ring shatter well the elden ring is made
up of runes and in a recent story
trailer we learned that the rune of
death was stolen so this seemed to kick
off the shattering process leading to
the deaths of the demigods and then to a
shattering war between them as each of
them tried to claim power the official
site even says even when fueled by the
power of a great rune no single side
could find enough purchase to maintain a
decisive victory
but somehow it seems we tarnished might
be able to break this stalemate by
becoming an elden lord
so what exactly is an elden lord
well if i had to guess it's probably
like being a lord of cinder just like
they unite powerful souls and burn for
the flame i would assume that we unite
the fragments of the elden ring and
embody it and unite it somehow in dark
souls you could link the fire and keep
the world order going but you could also
usher in different endings that align
with different sorts of beliefs just so
in olden ring the power of the ring
allows those in power to set or
interpret the golden law or the logic of
the world according to miyazaki this
golden order is something that the elden
ring may have once represented but not
directly it's more about how you apply
those rules and how you enforce them on
the physical world and what effects they
have on it so what kind of ruler you'll
be will matter a lot
marika and her kin controlled the elden
ring at one point and used its power to
lead an age of the odd tree according to
miyazaki in the sort of heyday of the
golden order of the lands between there
were two elden lords and godfrey was the
first of these he was married to the
eternal queen america and was
representative of this period of
grandeur and affluence in the network
test we also learned about an order of
knights who served godfrey this is the
crucible set and this one belongs to one
of 16 ancient knights who served godfrey
the first elden lord it reads the
vessels that cover this armor seethe
with the power of life's crucible that
same power that coursed through the odd
tree in its primordial form so godfrey's
knights were imbued with the primordial
power coursing through the odd tree
meaning that he was almost certainly a
powerful man during that age of the odd
tree the viridian amber medallion goes
on to say the odd tree's old sap becomes
amber treasured as the most precious of
jewels in the age of godfrey the first
elden lord
his power is so linked to the power of
the ode tree he might even be a part of
it in some way a recent tweet states his
memory still towers over the lands
between
and you know what else towers over the
lands between the earth tree now however
even godfrey's age has passed and he and
his knights are not looked upon too
kindly by history a description reads in
time the strength shown by these knights
and even their appearance came to be
looked upon with scorn for having such
close resemblance to chaos i think
obviously it's talking about the
primordial power of the odd tree being a
sort of power that is close to chaos and
this isn't liked for some reason it's so
disliked in fact that i'm pretty sure
this is a night called ordovis who was
one of the crucible's most foremost
nights and he's seen imprisoned in an
ever jail here evidels are sprinkled all
over the map that we've seen so far so
for one of godfrey's own knights to be
imprisoned in these jails suggests
hostility and punishment by whatever
force ended godfrey's reign
so even godfrey a man who surely accrued
a ton of power during the age of the
earth tree even he couldn't hold on to
his own age so first there was the age
of the ode tree then the age of godfrey
and now what
well now i think we're finally
approaching the events of the game
currently ruling over stormville castle
the first legacy dungeon of eldon ring
is godric one of queen america's demigod
children here godric's kingdom remains
at war long past the shattering and he
clings to a ruined legacy a husk rung
dry by war
and there seems to be a bit of dispute
about who the rightful king of stormvale
is
recent tweet states godric's claim as
the rightful golden king is not wholly
uncontested so i personally feel like
stormville might have belonged to
godfrey
there's an enormous painting of him
standing in the middle of a giant dining
hall in stormvale and it's actually this
same picture of godfrey where he stands
alongside his lion spirit stand thing
there are also lion banners alongside
the painting and the knights in this
area have that same lion crest upon
their armor so i'm pretty sure the lion
is a crest related to godfrey
according to the olden ring twitter
godric was born a weakling child and
coveted the strength of his kin just so
he literally grafts their arms onto his
own even many statues of america his own
mother supposedly have had their arms
removed
so even now there are those who plot to
see godric's crown pass into more worthy
hands and we might indirectly or
directly bring about that plot because
as we learned in the last trailer the
snow witch's tale is in need of the
ending perhaps a tarnished will be able
to provide one
and if we fail well tarnished seem to be
on the menu for grafting onto godric
there's even a force called tarnished
hunters who seek to dismember us
so why does godric value tarnished limbs
so highly
well it's probably because we both have
a common relative godfrey is logically
godric's father and godfrey is also our
tarnished ancestor and i come to this
conclusion because in a very early
interview miyazaki mentioned that our
tarnished ancestor was banished and
exiled and now in a recent edge magazine
interview miyazaki goes on to say that
godfrey himself became tarnished and he
shares this deep connection with the
player character he too was exiled from
the lands between and represents a lot
of what the player character stands for
this casts such a revealing light on who
the tarnished are and why they were
exiled we were kind of like exiled
through proxy thanks to godfrey it also
explains why godric values us but still
resents our diluted bloodline it
explains why we resurrect at statues of
america she was godfre's wife and
clearly we still have some of her favor
it might even explain this battle axe
description which reads
axes are known to have been favored by
the warrior king who led the long march
i marked this description as something
that might be explained later and i
didn't expect to answer it so quickly
because the long march is capitalized
and maybe this represented our long walk
into exile although that's just
speculation it's almost certain that
godfrey is this warrior king though he
favors axe weapons and him being a
warrior also goes on to explain this
dialogue from margate
i'm so curious to learn why
godfrey was exiled you know what did he
do to warrant all of this and all of
this hatred of his bloodline no less
[Music]
littering the lands between are these
enormous chunks of architecture embedded
far and wide across the entire known map
these aren't remains that are poking up
from beneath the earth nor they remains
of a structure that was on the earth
instead they're the ruin fragments of
what was once a temple in the sky many
of you will recognize this sky temple
concept as being inspired by hayao
miyazaki's castle in the sky a famous
film that featured this ancient yet
advanced civilization that was lost
their castle floating over the earth
obscured behind clouds eternally out of
sight at one point a huge robot from
that place falls to earth and what do
you know one such giant exists in eldon
ring as well or at least i think
it's surrounded by a group of giants
just like it and most importantly it
starts the fight at half health which
indicates to me that it might have just
survived the fall
but what caused this fall well if we
look at some leaked concept art of eldon
rings map
one can't help but notice the enormous
crater at the center of the lands
between
now this crater could have been caused
by the falling sky temple but a crater
like this feels like it was caused by a
meteorite and meteorite after all is a
sorcery in elden ring it's quite a
spectacular one actually fragments of
meteorite can also be found all over
limgrave and some folks even call
themselves star callers scavenging
desperately for these valuable shards to
some meteorites held the same importance
as stars and stars and the cosmos these
are incredibly important concepts in
olden rings law in fact stars and their
vitality are the entire basis for entire
branches of sorcery in this game and
that's a sorcery called glintstone
sorcery so what happens from a law point
of view when you cast a glintstone
sorcery well most sorceries scale with
intelligence and with your power of
comprehension you are tapping into the
vitality of the cosmos and channeling it
and to help channel its energy you use a
catalyst in the network test the only
catalyst available was the carrion
sorceress staff which even has a blue
glint stone embedded in its tip to aid
with this process of getting into the
flow of the cosmos these glintstones are
the amber of the stars and they are also
the symbol of the carrion royal family
and i'll tell you now if you decide to
make a sorcerer build carrier is a name
that you're going to read a lot it's an
old magical place that was led by the
lunar queen and the history with
glintstone and sorcery goes back a long
long way and while this family was
clearly incredibly proficient at
glintstone sorcery that doesn't mean
they didn't have competition
there was also an academy called the
raya lucaria academy which was formed
and it had agents that were so
proficient at sorcery that the carrion
royal family even saw fit to establish
an order of carrier knights to oppose
them but we'll talk about that later for
now you just need to know that back then
the carrion royal family was at its
height and remnants of their influence
appear all over the lands between the
telescope item in this game for example
is actually a part of a larger astrology
tool that was used by members of the
carrion royal family larger telescopes
are also a gameplay tool that you can
actually go up to and use throughout the
lands between to get a sense of your
surroundings so there really is evidence
everywhere that the carrion royal family
was a force here at one point because
stargazing and looking up and learning
from the cosmos was a huge thing at this
point i also want to commend sophie who
was speaking on sinclair law's channel
when she discovered that these giant
half stone vessels also found in the
network test are probably a type of
astrolabe and an astrolabe is an ancient
astrological instrument and the words
stone astrolabe are actually a word that
you can write in the online messaging
system of eldon ring so the clues are
everywhere and more than just practicing
glintstone sorcery carrier engaged in
stargazing and research but sorceress
selen says it best it should not be
forgotten
that glinstone's sorcery is the study of
the stars and the life therein
a fact lost on most sorcerers these days
however the power of carrier was doomed
to fail almost every description of the
carrion royal family mentions their
decline but the telescope description
says it best during the age of the odd
tree carrion astrology withered on the
vine the fate once writ in the night
skies became fettered by the golden law
it was bound by the elden ring remember
this line from the first trailer that
which commanded the stars
the olden ring commanded the stars and
it feels so good to finally understand
that line the elden rings golden order
shackled the fate once seen in the night
sky and the age of the earth tree that
it gave rise to ended up indirectly or
directly
causing carrion astrology to become
obsolete
glintstone and its research was
superseded by a more powerful force all
of a sudden the starry amber from the
stars was replaced by golden amber and
obviously this was terrible for carrier
but for the rest of the world perhaps it
was a good thing after all according to
that same narrator the olden ring is
responsible for
giving life
its fullest brilliance and this should
all remind you of gwyn's age of fire in
dark souls it was something that was
built on a lie but it was still a
beautiful age of warmth all the same
and the olden ring is the source of many
blessings upon the lands between
one such force of power were the odd
trees which secrete golden amber which
is a type of sap that contains a sort of
primordial life energy this life energy
is taken from the elden ring and if the
elden ring is commanding the stars maybe
the elden ring is getting its power from
the stars but that's just speculation
but whatever this golden amber is it's
powerful so powerful in fact that it
made carious glindstones of starry amber
obsolete
of course it was only obsolete in the
age of the earth tree while the olden
ring was commanding the stars
but of course as you know the alden ring
has shattered making this the perfect
time for a resurgence the raya lukarian
academy that we mentioned earlier they
leapt at the chance to regain relevance
now that the ring was shattered and they
experienced a total renaissance of
glinstone sorcery a forefather of this
renaissance was the wise carolos whose
visage is represented in this mask of
heavy stone
embedded with glintstone gems it
represents the total surrender of eyes
and mind to glintstone's study modern
scholars wear the mask to show their
lineage from carolos along with their
deep blue riolukarian robes which they
receive and take along with vows of
virtue and austerity however it also
says that with extended life one is apt
to forget old vows now it's unclear why
their lives are extended but clearly
this long life has had an effect upon
raya lucaria's culture
you have to remember elden ring makes
the shattering feel like it was a recent
event but it really was a long time ago
so long that its members are forgetting
the vows that they took back when they
were fledgling sorcerers the first step
on the journey of a new sorcerer is to
learn glintstone pebble which is a basic
spell we see it being cast here by the
noble sorcerer summon he's one of my
favorites because he actually has a
story
apparently he studied sorcery at raya
lucaria and after learning this spell
that was accomplishment enough for a
noble so it seems to imply that raya
lucaria's sorcery was for sale it was an
export to the nobles of the lands
between back in the day and this helps
to explain why this summon is so lovably
useless you know he left the academy
before he could be bothered to learn
anything more important than their most
basic spell more successful sorcerers
are encouraged to set off and travel
from the academy on journeys of
discovery and the spell that they give
to such wanderers is glintstone arc
which is this horizontal blade of magic
that is designed to protect them against
large groups of adversaries since it
cleaves through them really effectively
it reads fools often roam in packs a
line that betrays the arrogance that the
rya lucarian way is superior and that
those without intelligence should be
looked down upon which is also a common
sorcery trope in the soul series
basically every sorcerer you meet in
these games refuses to teach you unless
you have the required intelligence for
example talk to sorceress selen without
the required intellect and you'll get
this unique dialogue instead
a yen for glimstone sorceries
i dare say your proclivities are far
from ideal
oh well perhaps nurture will defy nature
with a bit of luck
but one must choose one's masters wisely
i was exiled from the academy of real
lucaria
as a reviled apostate witch
do you still wish to learn from me
you only learn this if you talk to her
without intellect but sorcerer's selling
was exiled from raya lucaria why well
maybe it was because she practiced magic
other than raya lukari and glindstone
sorcery for example here she teaches the
gravitational sorcery meteorite she
teaches the carrion sorcery bubbles
and perhaps most damningly she sells a
blood sorcery briars of sin this is an
aberrant sorcery discovered along with
red glintstone by those exiled to the
north for their crimes summons large
thorns from a whirl of blood shed by
one's own hand in penance for sins the
academy reviles this sorcery which draws
its power from faith and you know
usually in these games when there's
something that scales with intelligence
and faith it means there's a truth here
that either clerics or sorcerers don't
want to face because both sides really
hate each other so why is there this
overlap
the fact that this cosmic glintstone
might be related to the blood of life
probably makes the academy afraid for
some reason that's why they forbid this
type of sorcery but unfortunately
we know precious little about blood
sorcery and red glintstone for now so
subscribe and make sure you learn about
it later so to conclude the academy is
kind of beset on all sides they look
down on the ignorant masses they revile
those who use faith but that's not all
because they've also somehow made
enemies of fellow sorcerers that's not
common in these games
earlier we talked about the carrion
royal family and even back when they
were the ones in power they saw raya
lucaria as a threat so they formed an
order called the carrion knights who
were originally established to counter
the academy these knights carry shields
that reflect sorcery they cast glint
swords blessed by pure moonlight and
their helmets are even ornamented by
what looks like a queen chess piece
which is surely a reference to the lunar
queen of this carrion royal family of
course the carrion royal family and
their knights have fallen into disarray
but i'm pretty sure they would still be
a force in the world you know you
basically play as a carrier knight in
the network test using all of their
equipment and spells and by the way the
moonlight greatsword is gonna be in this
game you just know it they have an
entire
sect that's dedicated to the moon and
the blessings from it but yeah all of
these carrion item descriptions talk
constantly about their decline but i do
have a bit of theory about that what if
their decline was literal what if
carrier or some of them at least
ended up underground let me explain that
theory so every time you cast a spell in
these games a symbol will briefly flash
that shows the type of spell you're
using this is the symbol for blood
sorcery this is one for glintstone
sorcery and this spell magic bubble uses
the symbol for carrion sorcery and the
description of bubble reads a lost
ancient sorcery used by wretches who
dwell in underground ruins so it's
interesting that these wretches deep
below the ground
are using a spell that has a carrion
symbol of course it's still just a
theory that the carrion royal family
ended up deep underground i'll have to
thank loki for that one but it's a good
segue into our next fascinating topic
which is the eternal city a place lost
in ruin underground and a place that is
mentioned in all item descriptions in
the game so far that have to do with
gravity so meteorite for example is
still glintstone sorcery but it's one
that draws upon gravitational force
which is obviously still a very cosmic
force
this sort of gravitational sorcery was
used by a great white king or kings in
their eternal city where meteorites held
the same import as stars
and that's the end of the video i'm
sorry for the abrupt ending that
narration was recorded a really long
time ago and i kind of go on a rant
about the eternal city which might end
up being proven wrong in a few days so
maybe it's best to avoid that
and just see where we end up thank you
so much for watching i know this was a
long video and i hope it inspires you to
check out some item descriptions and
read about the law and really engage
with that part of elden ring as well
and i'll see you at launch on twitch and
on youtube but until then
take care